wise words of wisdom for aspiring actors
I think it's just you've got to be true
to yourself I think that's the bottom
line is that you kind of know your truth
you know you know if you have a secret
about something that's always my
touchstone is is you know if I can
imagine many other people playing the
part well and I think I haven't unlocked
the secret about it that means that I
should be the one to play it you know I
feel I have to have an edge I suppose or
something that a connection that means
that you can't ignore
it's it's something alchemical almost
and I think it's kind of speak your mind
too I think you never regret calling
someone on something you never regret
you know challenging I thought if if
it's what you feel you know if you feel
that something isn't on the page it
probably isn't and you know and I've
only learnt this in recent years I'd you
know there are plenty of times when I've
played parts and had a much more
interesting character in my head than
could ever be achieved on the screen
because it's ultimately it's in what
they the character does sometimes what
they say but usually what what they do
that leaves the sort of impact of that
person on the movie and on the audience
and often I've developed a kind of
complex set of you know contradictions
and internal worlds for people and
realized when I see the finished film or
you know no one's going to get any of
that you know so I think it's important
just sort of defend what you think about
things and for any English actor I would
say spend your money on a dialect coach
and master an American accent because
it's more and more and more useful and
it for me I think the dedication that
I've put into becoming fluent I would
say
American you know means that I can be as
free as I can in English when I'm
speaking American but only now and I
didn't I didn't no one gave me that
advice at the beginning of my career and
and and I was held back by it I think
because there was a time when you know I
could master the accent but I wasn't
free to inhabit it you know and that's
there's two different things and now you
know I can be as deft as as I can in
English with an English accent so that's
that's my strongest piece of advice I
think the myths well one I suppose is
that is that girls take longer in hair
and makeup and the boys anything that's
doing that's true at all
- is that it's glamorous any of my
friends who come and visit me on set say
almost universally wow this really is
not glamorous is it you know when they
sit around with people eating lunch out
of a cardboard box and not getting to go
to the bathroom six hours I think that's
one of them biggest biggest
misconceptions I think the only tip for
auditioning is is to go in there and be
prepared to play I think it's be
prepared to you know you know have your
take and be strong with your tape but
then be prepared to be malleable you
know and I think that's the fun I mean
most of the time people are wanting to
know if you can be directed and if you
can be free and and you know I think you
can you can surprise people with it's
it's about really how relaxed you can be
with their I know that's a sort of hard
thing to you know it's a hard thing to
do because the whole very nature of
auditioning means that you often feel
very nervous and you know feel you don't
look right but I think if you can kind
of that's one thing you can get what you
look like out of them out of the picture
because there are that's other people's
business basically I've learnt that in
later life what you look like is not
your responsibility that is the
responsibility of another department so
your responsibility is to bring truth
the character so I think especially
girls you know who probably go into an
audition and you know spend too long
before they go out doing their hair and
makeup and actually they have a better
place just kind of I don't know walking
through a park and feeling free and
making sure the lines are kind of in
their body you know directors are
sensitive people they directors want to
see what's in your soul not what's
what's here so things that help me I
mean when I started out there was a
there was a book called improv which I
found very inspiring because I think it
just makes you think freely and and
makes you
I found it as a kind of it's not
something necessary I've gone back to
there was also but the David Mamet wrote
called true true or false which was a
which was a great resource and sort of
you know it's sort of backs up one's
instincts and now I I really love
talking to actors about acting I really
crave that connection with other actors
and and and sometimes actors are quite
shy to really discuss it because there's
some part of it the process that feels
that almost I feel this that somehow if
you analyze it too much it might be it
might disappear you know that if you try
and touch it it'll it'll evaporate but
I've had a really good time recently
there's a there's a there's a
photographer in America called Sam Jones
who does a series of podcasts and video
chats called off-camera and I've really
really enjoyed seeing and listening to
those because he unlike most interviews
that you get which are edited and
somehow curtailed and often you know
steered towards an actor talking about
their particular movie that they're in
right now it's a sort of hour long
meandering through someone's career
aspirations what acting means to them
and often it he kind of makes gets
people into a comfortable enough space
that you really get something that feels
real and truthful and for me that's just
gold and it's um and it's really kind of
exciting when you hear things that
you know experiences that you can share
and you can identify with and you think
yes that's exactly what it's like or oh
I felt like that too or whatever you
know it's actors showing their
vulnerabilities and sharing those
vulnerabilities and often it's quite
it's candid and unusual so I'd say if
you're you know if you're interested in
acting go and check out some of those
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]